bonjour à tous c'est la fin des
questions au gouvernement on refait les
casques sur LCP on refait les questions
au Gouvernement très heureuse de vous
retrouver ici Salle des pas perdue juste
à côté de l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale ou vient de s'achever cette
séance de questions au Gouvernement la
dernière séance on va y revenir assez
longuement avec Stéphanie Despierre et
Elsa mandingava qui se trouve salle des
quatre colonnes et avec nos invités en
plateau je vous les présente pierre
Cazeneuve bonjour vous êtes député
renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine et Cyriel
châtelain bonjour président du groupe
écologiste ici à l'Assemblée nationale
alors on vous retrouve tout de suite
elles a mon ningava Elsa vous avez suivi
cette séance depuis les tribunes et
alors vous ce qui vous a marqué c'est un
échange assez fort entre le député
socialiste de Seine-et-Marne Olivier
Faure et le la et le ministre Olivier
vers le porte-parole Olivier du
gouvernement tout à fait les deux
Olivier faut savoir qu'ils ont une
histoire commune puisqu'ils étaient
députés socialistes sous le mandat de
François Hollande ça va peut-être vous
expliquer un petit peu l'échange qui a
suivi Olivier Faure premier secrétaire
une partie socialiste a dit à la
première ministre qu'elle avait
bénéficié d'un nouveau sursis puis il
est accusé le gouvernement d'être en
déconnexion alors qu'il considère que
l'objectif des 100 jours d'apaisement a
été rempli puis il s'est livré à une
tirade avec une anaphore vous savez les
socialistes en sont friand qu'avez-vous
apaisé à demander à plusieurs reprises
avec ironie le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste c'est donc le
porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
Véran ancien socialiste qui lui a
répondu il a critiqué en disant qu'il
faisait partie d'un parti qu'il avait
beaucoup aimé et qu'à son époque et bien
chez les socialistes c'était le travail
la sécurité la transition énergétique
qui comptait il a répondu à l'anaphore
qui avait vous apaisé par une autre
anaphore qu'avez-vous fait critiquant
les socialistes qui n'avaient pas assez
critiqué eux les insoumis pendant toute
la période des émeutes urbaines
je pense que le président eu raison de
accorder à nouveau sa confiance et
Elizabeth borne pour poursuivre le
travail qu'elle a entamé depuis un peu
plus d'un an aujourd'hui avec la
majorité avec son gouvernement un
gouvernement qui a été en action
effectivement la mission du président
c'était son jour pour apaiser pour
continuer à faire avancer un certain
nombre de sujets je prends l'exemple
c'était son jour d'apaisement après un
débat difficile sur la réforme des
retraites avec une volonté très forte de
renouer le dialogue social avec les
partenaires sociaux ces choses qui a été
faites tous les partenaires sont revenus
à la table des discussions des
négociations nous avons passé un très
beau texte de la retranscription fidèle
de l'accord qui avait été passé entre
les partenaires sociaux
c'est là aussi la preuve que sur ce
sujet là du travail nous arrivons nous
avons réussi à apaiser justement et à
aller de l'avant et je pense que c'est
ça le plus important aujourd'hui c'est
continuer à agir et dans ces 100 jours
nous avons multiplié encore une fois les
textes extrêmement importants que ça
soit là encore sur le sujet de
l'industrie verte on reviendra tout à
l'heure j'imagine sur les prix
l'électricité et surtout tu as un nombre
extrêmement important tout n'est pas
réglé
évidemment et que l'apaisement n'est pas
encore totalement arrivé on l'a vu avec
des scènes d'émeutes et de violence
urbaine très éprouvante pour les mères
pour les populations et je veux redire
ici tout mon soutien
à l'ensemble des forces de secours et
force de l'ordre qui ont été mobilisées
sur le terrain pour assurer la sécurité
de nos concitoyens voilà tout n'est il
reste encore beaucoup de travail et je
pense que c'est pour ça que le président
a fait confiance et Elisabeth band pour
continuer pour la stabilité c'est ça qui
l'a dit quand il a continué à être dans
l'action et à continuer à réformer parce
que ce pays en a besoin vous la voyez
vous le voyez vous l'apaisement vous
avez l'impression que avec cette
première ministre on va pouvoir
poursuivre le les réformes parce que
effectivement ici on les GIF faire
la première chose c'est qu'il veut dire
que les 100 jours c'est quelque chose de
complètement artificiel j'ai de France
moi j'ai pas vu d'avant ni d'après les
100 jours on a toujours la même
politique exactement la même qui revient
aujourd'hui à
moi contrairement je pense que la
question des retraites est pas passée je
sais que c'est un espèce que vous
l'espérez beaucoup mais en vrai
c'est pas un débat la première chose
c'est un c'est pas derrière nous on a eu
on aurait dû avoir un vote au mois de
juin il a été empêché ça prouve bien par
exemple il y a toujours pas de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale pour cette
réforme la deuxième chose c'est que en
septembre il y a des gens qui devaient
partir en retraite et qui partiront pas
et qui ont trois mois de travail en plus
ça c'est assez fasse pas avec son jour
c'est à dire que c'est une réforme qui
touche profondément la vie donc ça veut
dire quoi
c'est l'équivalent c'est l'équivalent du
5 euros d'appel du début du dernier
quinquennat c'est à dire que c'est
quelque chose qui va rester qui va
rester profondément avec un sentiment
d'injustice et le sentiment de pas avoir
été écouté ça c'est la première chose et
la deuxième chose sur ce remaniement moi
je suis interloquée par la méthode c'est
à dire que la méthode on dit de
renouveler sa confiance moi je vois
c'est-à-dire que c'est un off de ce que
je comprends c'est que c'est un texto en
off à un journaliste qui dit on
maintient une première ministre
quelle manière vous la voyez pas
confortée
pour vous pour la première vie
finalement une manière de continuer tout
en l'affaiblissant enfin c'est assez
terrible c'est à dire qu'on va continuer
d'avoir une première Mini ski là mais
dont on n'est pas complètement convaincu
qu'elle est la confiance du président
voilà donc on est on est toujours pour
moi dans un gouvernement qui
en incapacité de gouverner c'est à dire
qu'on verra la loi de programmation des
finances publiques je pense on avait
toujours pas de majorité
le
budgeté c'est sur des textes vides c'est
à dire que le meilleur exemple c'est le
texte on est en train d'étudier
industrie verte il n'y a rien de temps
alors pour Cyrielle Chatelain pierre
Cazeneuve on voit bien la première
ministre n'est pas suffisamment
confortée le président de la République
doit parler d'ici dimanche donc dans les
tous prochains jours est-ce qu'il doit
avoir un mot pour sa première ministre
et ce qu'il doit lui accorder sa
confiance
peut parler longuement de la forme un
texto communiqué presse je pense que
c'est pas la question président a été
extrêmement clair et la renouvelé et la
confiance de sa première ministre
aujourd'hui il lui a donné la charge
également de réfléchir à quelques
ajustements dans l'équipe
gouvernementale ça c'est pas de la
confiance je sais pas ce qu'il vous faut
dire l'inverse de la confiance c'était
il aurait pu se séparer de sa première
liste il ne l'a pas fait donc je pense
qu'il y a le débat est clos par rapport
à ça et ça a beaucoup agité notre notre
petit microcosme politique et médiatique
mais fondamentalement le débat est clos
aujourd'hui le président a renouveler sa
confiance et Elisabeth borne pour
poursuivre son action donc peu après
discuter de la forme mais les résultats
et donc le cap que vous avez entamé
prendra la parole là aussi pour fixer le
cap sur les réformes qui sont
prioritaires pour lui je pense qu'on a
pensé il y aura évidemment le sujet de
la transition écologique et énergétique
en premier plan il y aura les sujets
évidemment du travail sur lequel on a
envie de continuer à réformer parce
qu'il y a des actions encore à mener sur
ce sujet avec notre objectif de pleine
emploi qui qui est bientôt avec toute
notre stratégie de réindustrialisation
parce que je peux pas vous laisser dire
que dans le texte industriel qui est un
texte extrêmement structurant pour
continuer à réindustrialiser et
décarboner notre notre industrie en
France voilà c'est tout ça vient dans
une logique très forte avec un volonté
de revenir et une certaine forme de
souveraineté française je me souvienne
industrielle une souveraineté
énergétique d'être le pays le premier
pays à sortir du fossile et ça c'est des
ambitions le président va nous projeter
aussi vers cette translate France
ambitieuse du plein emploi et des cartes
parce qu'on va évoquer les prix
d'électricité ça a fait l'objet de
plusieurs questions cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale les
tarifs vont augmenter de 10% au premier
août et c'est le député RN de l'Aube
Jordan Guitton qui a interpellé le
gouvernement on écoute la réponse que
lui a fait de la ministre de la
transition écologique Agnès panière une
hachée
l'irresponsabilité monsieur le député
Guiton elle est du côté de ceux qui ont
refusé de voter ces dispositifs elle est
du côté du rassemblement national car
comme à son habitude vous parlez
beaucoup mais vous faites peu au
contraire nous avons pris nos
responsabilités sinon n'avions pas agile
les factures des Français auraient
doublé en février et vous le savez selon
la Commission de régulation l'énergie il
est tarifs d'électricité aurait été
augmenté de près de 75% le gouvernement
n'a pas suivi ce calcul et à opter pour
une autre limitée de 10%. aussi nous
serons extrêmement vigilants avec le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
Monsieur le Maire le maintien du
bouclier tarifaire permettra de prendre
en charge plus du tiers je le répète
plus du tiers de la facture des Français
c'est massif monsieur le député et nous
accordons à un droit de réponse à Jordan
Guitton qui est posé sa question tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle députés ARN de
l'aube il est au micro de Stéphanie des
pierres bonjour qu'avez-vous pensé de la
réponse de la ministre alors je trouve
que la ministre a été comme d'habitude
c'était une réponse de réaction sur le
marché de l'électricité on sait qu'on a
des mesures qui sont bonnes à prendre
pour faire baisser les prix
d'électricité et la ministre finalement
a été à réaction et le problème de
gouvernement c'est qu'il n'agit jamais
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français il
réagit l'oublier le bouclier torréfair
est une réponse politique à une problème
étant qu'on aura pas traité les causes
alors les conséquences seront toujours
les mêmes l'augmentation interne des
prix de l'électricité ou le paiement par
l'impôt des Français par le bouquet
tarifaire de l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité nous aura sûrement
national nous proposons de désindexer le
prix de l'électricité sur celui du gaz
de manière à permettre aux Français de
retrouver du pouvoir d'achat et de
baisser réellement les prix de
l'électricité la ministre dit que vous
proposez mais que vous n'avez pas voté
les mesures de soutien aux Français pour
affronter ces prix d'électricité mais en
fait c'est complètement faux tous les
toutes les primes qui ont été votées en
juillet l'année dernière nous les avons
votés et tout le reste du budget a été
adopté en 49-3 donc nous n'avons pas pu
nous exprimer dessus
merci beaucoup
Cyril châtelain est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec Jordan Guitton quand il
dit qu'il faut décorer les prix du gaz
de l'électricité en clair réformée ce
marché européen de l'électricité
la première de l'énergie
je l'ai déjà dire un que les écologistes
ont aussi posé cette question
d'augmentation du prix de l'énergie et
que c'est un combat qu'on mène depuis
longtemps qui est comment réformer le
calcul du prix de l'énergie au niveau
européen mais moi je voudrais revenir au
cœur du débat qui a aujourd'hui c'est
dire l'augmentation de 10% il y a eu un
choix qui a été fait effectivement d'un
bouclier tarifaire qui a protégé tous
les ménages qui soient modestes classe
moyenne ou très riche contre des hausses
très conséquentes on sait avec des aides
conséquentes et on sait que aujourd'hui
ce qui consomme le plus d'électricité
donc ceux qui ont été le plus aidés
financièrement ce sont les ménages les
plus riches
euh voilà c'est en fait c'est exactement
la même chose sur l'aide sur donc
progressif de l'électricité alors oui à
la question du tarif progressif bien
évidemment mais comme bouclier tarifaire
ce qu'on aurait pu faire ce qu'on avait
proposé ce qui était faisable c'était de
dire en fait on regarde ce qu'on
normalement on consomme pour vivre
logiquement cuisiner se laver se
chauffer et donc ça on aide bien
évidemment c'est à dire que là on régule
on a une aide pour que ça soit modérée
et qui est pas d'augmentation des prix
c'est-à-dire pour toutes les classes
moyennes et toutes les ménages modestes
et tout ce qui dépasse davantage
consommation et ben en fait on met on
juste on laisse au prix du marché
puisqu'il y a pas de raison que on
finance par de l'argent public une
surconsommation d'électricité et donc ça
pour nous c'est un c'était une problème
la manière dont se bouclier était pensé
et si on avait pensé ce bouclier là sans
doute déjà qu'il aurait coûté moins cher
qu'il aurait été plus juste et donc
aujourd'hui on aurait pas la même
question c'est-à-dire qu'on aurait
dépensé moins d'argent de manière mieux
cibler on aurait aidé ce qu'on a besoin
et on aurait envoyé un signal prix au
ménage les plus riches qui dit ben non
en fait il faut modérer il faut de la
sobriété dans son utilisation de la
consommation d'énergie est-ce qu'on
aurait pu mieux faire sur le bouclier
tarifaire sur l'électricité mais aussi
blesser aides déjà effectivement il faut
avoir en tête que 10% d'augmentation
c'est beaucoup pour de nombreux ménages
ça va représenter par très significatif
sur la facture et donc on fait jamais on
prend jamais ce genre de décision à la
légère parce que effectivement pour de
nombreux foyers ça va être c'est une
très très difficile nous-mêmes après 15%
déjà en février ensuite
redire évidemment que l'État a aidé
massivement massivement l'ensemble des
Français avec un tarif avec un bouclier
tarifaire c'est plus de 40 milliards en
deux ans donc c'est vraiment une aide
massive de l'État pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des Français encore
aujourd'hui le prix de l'électricité il
est 30% moins cher en France que dans la
moyenne des pays européens je pense que
c'est extrêmement important de se
rappeler même avec les augmentations qui
sont donc voilà malheureusement on est
aussi frappé par un choc inflationniste
en Europe dû à la guerre en Ukraine qui
a des conséquences et donc l'idée a été
de
mesurer cette hausse là de la contenir
un maximum et de progressivement parce
que l'État ne peut pas compenser
indéfiniment ces milliards là de
rehausser progressivement pour pas qu'il
y ait de choc trop importants ensuite tu
peux peut-être étonner la présidente moi
c'est des propositions qui qui ne me
choque pas et au contraire je pense
qu'on a tout intérêt à regarder je porte
par ailleurs le sujet de la tarification
progressive sur une question comme l'eau
ou je pense que là aussi on pourrait on
pourrait se rejoindre évidemment que
certains certains dispositifs peut être
améliorés sur la plante sociale je veux
quand même le redire que au-delà du
tarif au-delà du tarif réglementé donc
de ce bouclier massif nous avons aussi
fait des chèques énergie pour justement
là pour cibler les ménages les plus
modestes
évidemment qu'on peut encore progresser
mais voilà redire aussi ce qui a été
fait encore une fois l'étape en charge
30% du prix de l'électricité pour les
ménages nulle part ailleurs dans le
monde c'est fait l'État a mis 40
milliards pour protéger les ménages
nulle part ailleurs
aucun pays ne fait ne fait autant donc
on peut toujours améliorer je suis
d'accord avec vous mais voilà
reconnaissance qui a été fait et enfin
je veux dire un dernier petit mot je
pense c'est très important et je ne
résiste pas mais pas rentrer dans des
théories très complexes sur le la
manière dont tu es designer le marché de
l'énergie européenne mais un truc qui
est certain c'est extrêmement simple à
comprendre sur l'électricité et son prix
c'est que plus vous produisez
l'électricité moins cher et pour
produire plus d'électricité on a deux
moyens des énergies renouvelables et
l'énergie nucléaire heureusement le
nucléaire
ont voté ni l'un ni l'autre j'aurais pas
respecté ou l'un ou l'autre ils ont voté
ni l'un ni l'autre et donc aujourd'hui
on le sait on a massivement besoin de
produire de l'énergie
décarbonée de manière souveraine en
France on a massivement besoin de
produire cette électricité parce qu'on
va électrifier nos usages également des
carboner notre industrie en plus besoin
d'aller plus besoin d'électricité et
donc si on veut de l'électricité pas
cher
le premier sur le nucléaire parce qu'on
y est opposé le deuxième sur les
énergies renouvelables parce que c'était
pas suffisamment ambitieux et que la
France est clairement à la traîne sur la
question des énergies renouvelables on
aurait eu l'occasion d'avoir une grande
c'était pas déjà un premier pas c'était
pas
écologiste la question ça suffit les
petits pas les premiers pas là il faut
faire le pas faire le dernier mais la
vérité c'est on s'est abstenu pour
permettre au texte de passer donc on
sait absolument pour qu'il puisse passer
pour ne pas le bloquer mais de là les
donner la validation ce n'était pas
possible la deuxième chose c'est en fait
on n'est pas d'accord sur le modèle
c'est-à-dire que il faut toujours
produire plus d'énergie donc aujourd'hui
on sait qu'on est sur un modèle où il
faut produire la question c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on produit de l'énergie et
qu'est-ce qui nous permettra de produire
de l'énergie dans un monde où
aujourd'hui on est en France à plus 1,9
degrés et ben la question c'est un on
veut produire de l'énergie mais pour des
biens essentiels y compris dans les
biens essentiels il y a la question de
l'industrie etc mais c'est pas on va
consommer toujours plus d'énergie donc
on doit en produire toujours plus ça
c'est un modèle qui ne marche plus et la
deuxième chose sur le nucléaire
au-delà de ça aujourd'hui on va sur un
mur énergétique parce qu'on a même avec
la loi votée de toute façon plus
suffisamment de nucléaire et qu'en plus
on est dans un monde qui réchauffé et on
sait par exemple que l'été le nucléaire
a des difficultés à fonctionner au vu de
la demande de l'eau ou du réchauffement
de l'eau c'est un fait c'est en
attendant on a besoin de ce nucléaire
oui mais on a besoin de se qui ne
fonctionne pas l'été dans un monde qui
se réchauffe donc il faut le dire
clairement et en plus on a fait des
choix typiquement sur l'énergie de tout
mettre en quasiment en électricité c'est
à dire que le chauffage électrique c'est
un choix très français c'est un choix
très français qui font qu'on ait une
surconsommation d'électricité l'hiver
elle sans doute qu'il faut aller vers
d'autres choix et qu'on peut déjà
commencer par rénover si on renomme on
commence à moins donc pour nous c'est un
la sobriété de le renouvelable et
d'arrêter avec ce mythe du nucléaire qui
pourrait toujours continuer aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le cas et notamment dans
une planète qui se réchauffe pour une
pour une énergie maintenant la Cour des
comptes qui me dit donc c'est c'est ce
n'est pas seulement les écologistes
c'est à dire dans les prélèvements de
l'eau 50% des prélèvements de l'eau qui
sont faits en France vont pour le
nucléaire donc on est bien sur NRJ qui a
besoin d'eau dans prélever si c'est un
quand je vois pierre gazon
50 % de l'eau prélevés 20 sur le
nucléaire et aujourd'hui quand il y a
plus suffisamment d'eau
ça fonctionne à partir de l'eau donc
quand il y a moins d'eau donc on peut
pas la prélever ou clos est trop chaude
pour refroidir les réacteurs ça ne
marche pas c'est c'est pour ça arrive à
se moduler donc quand les températures
de l'eau effectivement augmentent les
nucléaires baissent un peu sa puissance
justement pour avoir moins besoin d'eau
pour fonctionner et pour pouvoir
remettre ces questions environnementale
de l'eau qui ne soit pas trop chaude
dans les cours d'eau par ailleurs les
nouveaux réacteurs qu'on est en train
qu'on a déjà
identifié à panli et à Gravelines c'est
au bord de la mer on n'est pas encore à
des niveaux de réchauffement de l'eau
qui va nous permettre de pas les faire
mais juste deux éléments par exemple
nous c'est nouveau vous nous parlez des
nouveaux réacteurs j'entends pour nous
parler des nouveaux réacteurs prêt on va
dire d'ici 15 ans si on est optimiste
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 et de l'efficacités
vous avez entendu on se rejoint mais
dans les mots et alors mais l'exemple je
trouve du bouclier tarifaire est un bon
exemple moi je suis ravi d'entendre que
vous trouviez ça intéressant c'est
dommage on l'entraîne beaucoup de points
d'accord sur ce plateau non mais on l'a
proposé au PLF il s'est fait balayer on
l'a reproposé on a proposé des
simulations
ça a été balayé sur la question de la
sobriété mais nous on demande que ça on
a aujourd'hui loin industrie verte on
refuse de parler de la modération de
l'eau de la modération de la
consommation d'énergie donc aujourd'hui
il y a pas de sobriété dans les faits et
l'efficacité on attend toujours l'argent
alors pour la rénovation des bâtiments
on va parler maintenant de la santé il
en était question cet après-midi avec la
fermeture de plusieurs services
d'urgence alors que la canicule sévit
elle a député liotte Martin Froget a
posé une question à François Brown on
écoute le ministre de la Santé nous
manquons de professionnels de santé sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et
pour former un médecin je le redis c'est
dix ans donc nous n'aurons pas de
solution miracle dans les les mois et
les années qui viennent les axes que
nous développons sur ces solutions c'est
redonner plus de temps aux
professionnels plus de temps auprès du
patient et les engager dans une logique
territoriale pour mieux répondre aux
besoins de santé de notre population je
rappellerai simplement pour le cas des
urgences non pas la fermeture dont
beaucoup de gens parlent mais qui est
dans l'immense majorité des cas ce que
l'on appelle un accès régulé régulé par
l'appel préalable au 15 sinon
concitoyens pensent qu'ils ont un
problème d'urgence pour qu'on leur donne
la meilleure solution et la meilleure
solution n'est pas d'aller
systématiquement vers le service
d'urgence elle peut être aussi d'aller
voir un médecin généraliste vrai
d'ailleurs dans la campagne la
possibilité de visualiser très simple
près de chez vous les médecin
généraliste disponible pour les soins
non programmés
et nous retrouvons à présent Isabelle
Valentin qui avait posé une question
aussi sur la santé au micro de Stéphanie
Despierre elle est députés les
républicains de la Haute-Loire est-ce
que les déclarations de François Bourne
le ministre de la Santé vous ont un peu
rassuré non absolument pas effectivement
puisque on attend une loi autonomie
grand âge depuis 6 ans on devait avoir
le texte bien vieillir qui devait
arriver en fin de semaine il est encore
été supprimé et effectivement on a
besoin de moyens supplémentaires pour
nos établissements de santé et pour nos
EHPAD et on voit que rien n'arrive alors
moi je veux bien on nous parle de
l'ambition c'est bien l'ambition on n'a
pas besoin d'ambition on a surtout
besoin de moyens financiers humains
merci beaucoup
pierre Cazeneuve il y a effectivement
ces mesures d'urgence là c'est services
d'urgence qui ferme l'été s'annonce
assez chaud il y a des épisodes de
canicules un peu partout est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour nos aînés
je me permets juste de faire une
précision qui est extrêmement importante
dans la chou dans le choix sémantique
les services d'urgence ne ferment pas là
c'est quand même très important pour le
dire aux Français qui peuvent
s'inquiéter nous regardent à la
télévision les services d'urgence
restent bien évidemment ouvert 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 ce qu'on fait c'est
de la régulation c'est à dire
qu'effectivement vous devez aujourd'hui
la nuit appelez le 15 avant d'être
redirigé vers les urgences famille il y
avait évidemment les services d'urgences
restent ouverts et
aux urgences exactement et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on est exactement et qu'on
est obligatoirement pardon une
régulation donc c'est juste très
important je pense que c'est
collectivement on a une responsabilité
par rapport à ça parce qu'il y a des
gens qui ne regardent qui peuvent
s'inquiéter de ça des services d'urgence
reste ouvert il faut juste appeler le 15
sur l'urgence effectivement on fait le
15 et on ne va aux urgences que dans des
cas extrêmes je pense qu'en fait on
revient sur la sémantique parce que si
on regarde sur le fond c'est
catastrophique je comprends que vous
préfériez des battes de la fibre optique
moi je veux parler des services
aujourd'hui
d'urgence qui en fait ce qu'on les gens
c'est des informations comme quoi partir
de 20h ils peuvent plus y accéder que
s'il y accède il y a un filtre via les
pompiers et donc c'est une inquiétude
totale parce que pour beaucoup les
urgences comme on a plus de médecins
c'est le dernier lieu on peut aller et
au-delà de ça les urgences c'est le
symptôme c'est le symptôme on a des
services pédiatriques de de chirurgie
pédiatrique qui ont dû reporter plus de
1000 opérations parce qu'il y a plus
d'infirmières pédiatriques en bloc
quelles sont en burn-out qu'elles sont
épuisées donc aujourd'hui on a un
problème à l'hôpital c'est à dire que
c'est chaque service au fur et à mesure
qui est en train d'être fragilisé et
donc oui les gens sont et le débat pour
suivre avec le projet de loi de finances
de la sécurité sociale ce sera à la
rentrée on va retrouver tout de suite
Marielle Duran qui est une dessinatrice
qu'on a vu tout au long de l'année qui a
croqué l'assemblée et l'hémicycle
pendant de nombreuses séances de
questions au gouvernement et comme c'est
la dernière séance et bien elle est avec
nous cette semaine et à votre micro elle
dans mon Agava oui et elle nous fait le
plaisir et bien d'avoir croqué cette
séance de notre côté nous elle CP
première image elle est importante c'est
un passage obligé celui du maquillage
une façon de rendre hommage à nos super
maquilleuses deuxième image que vous
avez choisi c'est votre plateau regardez
Brigitte vous êtes juste là qu'est-ce
que vous en retenez de ce qui s'est
passé
surtout
une sorte de d'échange très vif
d'autant plus qu'avec l'écho de la salle
des pas perdus on se doit d'être très
concentré
très concentré on voit c'est un peu
votre spécialité sur votre dessin très
peu de couleurs quel est votre code
alors moi c'est bleu blanc rouge en
réalité
donc pour les couleurs de la nation
et aussi avoir un code graphique très
fort c'est pas le plus simple à utiliser
mais voilà j'avais déjà utilisé ça à New
York pour un projet et je trouvais que
c'était assez symbolique en fait pour
l'assemblée et dernière image vous nous
avez accompagné en tribune presse ça
change de là où vous êtes habitué
d'habitude vous êtes de ce côté gauche
de l'hémicycle là vous aviez beaucoup
plus de recul oui c'est un une vue
d'ensemble qui est assez intéressante
même si on voit les députés de dos et un
peu plus petit donc je peux moins faire
de portraits et de de gros plan mais ça
donne aussi cette vue voilà qui permet
de d'embrasser un petit peu tous les
mycles merci beaucoup Marielle Durand de
nous avoir accompagné toute cette saison
vos destins seront aux journées du
patrimoine à l'Assemblée on y reviendra
voilà ce sera les 16 et 17 septembre
pour les Journées du Patrimoine ici à
l'Assemblée merci Marielle Durand de
nous avoir suivi tout au long de cette
journée merci à nos invités qui ont
trouvé que ces dessins ressemblaient
finalement assez bien au chaudron de
l'Assemblée nationale merci célèbre
châtelain merci Pierre cadenas de nous
avoir accompagnés pour cette dernière
séance de questions au gouvernement on
se retrouve bien entendu à la rentrée
sur LCP
[Musique]